guys
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to the fifth episode of queen
trap sack lines in this episode i am
going to show you one of the wonderful
queen sacrifice line in the green field
exchange variation from the black
perspective
here white start with the move c4 but it
quickly transposed to the greenfield
defense after the following model that
is knight to f6 d4
g6
knight to c3 and now the characteristic
gunfield move d5
now amongst all the possibility the most
popular choice by the white is to play
the exchange variation which happens
after the move order
c captures d5 knight captures d5 e4
knight capture c3 and now pawn capture
c3
i think both the side have their trunks
over here
as a wide you get this tremendous space
in the center
but black is more than happy because
just like pock and the alakan defense
black is going to hit back this center
and get some tactical possibilities
let's follow the main line for a while
bishop to g7 bishop to c4
and now black start undermining the
white center with this obvious move c5
so you can see i have highlighted by the
green arrows
black is clearly targeting this d4 pawn
and white has to play some accurate
moves to keep his center intact
for example he cannot play the move
knight to f3 the simple reason is after
bishop to g4
black's aim of pressurizing the d4
square will continue
so the accurate response over here is
knight to e2 so in case of bishop to g4
white can always continue with the f3
and unpin this knight
okay back to our main line business
c catches d4 c captures d4
knight to c6 attacking three times on
the d4 square
so white has to defend with the move
bishop to e3 and now
black deliver this queen check
kindly note if queen comes in between
then black can exchange this queen and
in those cases the position will remain
balanced
so white has to block this track with
the bishop
and afterwards black is going to play
this
tricky sideline move queen to a3
so idea is very simple
black wants to keep pressurizing the d4
square
now when i check this position in online
database i found out that
at this position the highest played move
is
rook to b1
and let us understand why this is the
case
well it's a very tactical move by white
and the important point is black cannot
even touch the d4 pawn
for example if black takes with the
bishop then the simplest is white can
take this bishop and after knight takes
white can immediately wince black queen
after the move bishop to b4
so that's not a good choice for the
black
well what happens if you take with the
knight
well more or less same story here what
is going to capture your knight and
after black recapture
white has this lethal check
which i think more or less stemmed the
victory
for example if you play the move king to
d8 then after bishop to b4
once again you will lose your queen so
that is completely out of the box
if king to f8 then white has this
another lethal check bishop to h6
and now white is hitting the bishop
and if black foolish enough to play the
move bishop to g7
then he is going to lose his king
so last but not least what happens if
you play bishop to d7
well this time around white has this
sequence that is bishop captures
king captures
and now bishop to b4
and definitely this position is
disgusting for the black
so it is very clear that at this
position black cannot touch this d4 pawn
but white's idea is more nasty than this
let's consider a casual move by black
such as h6
well here comes the whole point
white wants to play the move d5
and when you move this knight let's say
to e5
then white wins immediately after the
move push up to p4
and now this black baby is completely
trapped
so you can understand now how dangerous
this rook to b1 move is
well considering all this before i move
on i like you to pause this video and
find out
an amazing move played by the black
which can completely trick white's idea
well i hope you find this
super surprising move
castle on the king's side
when i see this game first time i
thought is black is mad
can't you see that his queen is going to
trap
well believe it or not but this is
exactly black ones
let's see what black is up to
so white is obviously going to execute
hisplan with the move d5 hitting the
knight and after knight to e5 and bishop
to b4
yes indeed black queen is completely
trapped
so the big question arises
why black allow white to do such a nasty
business
the ball is in your card i want you to
pause this video and find out
the amazing reply by black
well sometimes we really get amazed and
surprised by the beauty of chess
and this is one of the clear case
and here black has this dazzling move
i hope you guessed it
yep it's queen to f3
what a move
well first important point
if i take your queen
then
there comes
knight check
came to f1 and now bishop to h3 is
actually a checkmate
so it is very obvious that white cannot
even touch that
amazingly placed queen
and the problem is if white cannot take
this queen then black is attacking two
sports and white cannot defend both of
them
so this is one of the wonderful queen
set trick which happens actually 12
times in the real feeder games
i just like to show you the list of
those 12 games in the mega database
so as you can see from the list over
here that where there are some higher
ranked player
fallen into this wonderful queen
sacrifice streak
and if you check on the result side
there is not a single win for the white
now to understand the power of this
position and how quickly your opponent
can demolish
i like to show you a game which is old
one but nevertheless a very good game
where after castle
cosmina who is the in charge of the
black pieces continue with the move
queen captures e4
so at this point not only black is a
clear pawn up
but
white has some shattered pawn on the
queen side
white slight square bishop is attacked
so it has to move this bishop
in the game her opponent continued with
the move bishop to b5
and now the following sequence happened
queen to h4
f3
and now bishop to f5 hitting the rook
white responded with the
counter-attacking move bishop to even
but after queen to f6 it is very obvious
that
white has to move the rook
in the game he continued with the move
rook to c1
but then comes this double attack
so white response is force white has to
block the check with the moon knight to
d4
which at first sight saving everything
but after black's next amazing reply
knight catches f3 check
i think game is already gone
well white doesn't have any good choice
in the game why decided to play
g captures f3 but after bishop captures
d4 check
king to g2
and bishop to e3
black is indeed threatening a piece
well again white doesn't have any good
choices in the game he played
rook to c3 but after queen captures rook
captures
one move and white resigned
can you spot this move
well i hope you find this wonderful blow
bam
so a deflection move which wins the
white rook and in fact the game
well i hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful queen sacrifice line in the
greenfield exchange edition
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and i'll meet you in my next
episode very soon
bye and take care